everyone heading to these olympics is
taking
a step into the unknown the first hurdle
for athletes and media arriving in japan
making sure all the right paperwork is
in place to pass strict
covid19 safety protocols well we've just
made it through a fairly complex
immigration process that took around
four hours and involved taking a covid
test
i also had to take two coveted tests in
the days immediately prior
to coming to japan and i'll be tested
every day for the first three days and
then at regular intervals
after that as for the athletes we'll go
through something very similar
but they will be tested every single day
that they're at these olympics
some public health experts are concerned
the efforts being taken to keep these
games safe
don't go far enough for example the
daily test athletes are taking is a
rapid result anti-gen
test not the more reliable and accurate
pcr test
i think the fundamental problem was a
lack of
open transparent and scientific
discussions
about the conditions under which the
olympics
could be held in a safe and secure
manner
i think that that is totally
irresponsible
coronavirus has already derailed the
plans of many potential olympians
uganda's rugby sevens team were hoping
to compete at the games for the first
time
but after some of their players tested
positive for kovid 19 at their final
qualifying event
they had to withdraw and similar
scenarios are already playing out in
japan
the preparation has been very very
difficult for many athletes
and of course that experience has not
been uh similar
um the the virus has impacted some
countries
uh in a devastating way hugs
handshakes and high fives are all banned
at the athletes village
competitors have been told they could be
kicked out of the games
if they ignore regulations aimed at
preventing the spread of coronavirus
but not all athletes are concerned by
the restrictions as they focus on
winning
olympic gold you can't congregate in big
groups in a dining hall you got to stay
in your little bubble of four or five
people the whole time and stay to your
room and all of that
that's exactly how i've always treated
olympic games like it hasn't been a big
sociable
experience for me it's all about the
competition and so it's going to be
pretty routine
that sense of isolation is set to
continue into the fanless
empty stadiums that will surround an
olympics like no other
andy richardson al jazeera tokyo